bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7
fit sport il est 18h32 si vous nous
suivez en direct on passe tout de suite
au titre en image de cette édition
depuis le 1er mai la Ligue des Yvelines
de tennis a lancer l'opération balle
rose ou comment attirer les femmes sur
les cours éléments de réponse avec not
invités il est le premier pilote
instructeur de planeur handicapé de
France à 29 ans Antoine mtillon passe
désormais son temps entre les nuages et
pourtant il y a 9 ans il regardaient les
avions d'en bas c'est notre portrait de
la semaine guancour est encore en vie en
promotion d'honneur après leur victoire
face à la lanterne rouge sainclou ce
weekend les joueurs de J talmose peuvent
croire plus que jamais au maintien en PH
évidemment en fin d'émission tous les
résultats du weekend on passe tout de
suite à notre page spéciale tennis
féminin
je le disais dans les titres de cette
édition depuis le 1er mai et ce jusqu'au
30 juin la 2e édition de l'opération bal
rose lancé par la Ligue des ivelines de
tennis se déroule ou comment attirer
évidemment les femmes sur les cours vous
l'avez compris éléments de réponse avec
nos invités présents ce soir sur le
plateau du 78 sport à ma gauche l'UR
Morau on commence par les dames St F
présidente de la commission
communication de la Ligue des ilines
bonsoir à vous merci d'être là vous êtes
accompagné de Stéphane fugas que l'on
connaît bien directeur général de la
Ligue de tennis des ivilines bonsoir à
vous bonsoir Anthony merci tout d'abord
première question quand on prépare
uneémission il y a un chiffre très
parlant Stéphane à l'heure actuelle
c'est que les femmes ne représentent que
28 % des licenciés de tennis dans le
département c'est trop peu on a envie de
dire non je suis totalement d'accord
notre objectif c'est c'est de les
ramener à 33 % mais toujours avec une
une progression à la fois hommes et
femmes jeunes filles et et femmes adules
lor vous êtes présidente de la la
commission communication de la Ligue
vous êtes présente parce que évidemment
vous aidez énormément les clubs qui
participent à cette opération bal rose
je sais que vous êtes aussi pratiquante
de tennis comment on peut faire venir
les femmes sur les cours quelle est la
solution je il y a peut-être pas de
solution miracle évidemment mais en a
évidemment je je ne vous donnerai pas de
solution miracle ce qu'on essaie de
faire c'est de leur
ben de présenter le tennis sous un un
angle un peu plus ludique que que ce
qu'on a l'habitude de de voir jusqu'à
présent
donc le message qu'on leur fait passer
c'est osez le tennis venez découvrir le
tennis lors des animations qui sont mis
en place dans dans les clubs notamment
au cours de l'opération bal rose parce
qu'il y a plein de choses très simples
qui se qui se déroule et qui sont en
général très sympathiques quand on
regarde un peu les autres sports en
général on va dire discipline toute
confondu les femmes représentent à peu
près 40 % donc là on est quand même à 10
% 12 % de moins c'est un chiffre
alarmant ou pas pour le directeur
général que vous êtes non c'est a il y a
pas de lieu de s'alarmé parce que en
vité les les globalement c'est très
positif avec aujourd'hui sur le
département le tennis c'est 40 plus de
45000 licenciés 45086 en 2013 donc c'est
quand même le premier département de
France quand à la pratique du tennis
c'est 3,2 % de Tau de pénétration et
puis c'est le premier sport sur le
département 45000 pour le tennis
derrière c'est le le football 33000 le
golf 30000 l'équitation 22000 et puis le
judo 16000 17000 donc voilà nos chiffres
sont sont très bons simplement on
voudrait conserver C ce juste équilibre
deux hommes pour une femme et pourquoi
pas il y a des clubs qui réussissent à
avoir des des taux de féminisation de 40
% donc c'est possible qu'est-ce qui fait
que les femmes ne viennent pas encore en
masse sur les cours de tennis Stéphane
alors c'est il y a la réponse celle
d'hier et puis la répse d'aujourd'hui
parce que elle venait d'une manière plus
plus comment dire en nombre plus plus
important il y a une dizaine d'années ça
représentait grosso modo 5000 nouvelles
je parle de nouvelles pratiquantes qui
arrivé dans les clubs et aujourd'hui ce
il y a une lente érosion depuis 10 ans
ça ne représente plus qu'un flux de de
allez 4100 4200 donc il y a globalement
le tennis féminin c'est c'est allez
c'est reçoit les mêmes chiffres avec une
petite perte mais c'est pas tant le le
renouvellement les clubs m mis en place
des actions quand les gens arrivent qui
qui permettent qui ont amélioré la
fidélisation via tous les services il y
a de plus en plus de compétences en
terme d'ofre de service et d'outils
d'information via l'outil ad hoc mis en
place par la Fédération ou ou de base de
données d'adhérent de réservation de
cours et cetera par contre il y a une
problématique certainement d'image du
tennis où le tennis c'est pas forcément
un sport facile même si on est en plein
dans une réforme fédérale des moins de
12 ans avec des évolutions pédagogiques
mais il y a vraiment problème d'image il
y a aussi un problème de de crise je
pense que la la première qui dans un
ménage se sacrifie c'est la femme on va
dire c'est toujours les jeunes et les
hommes d'abord et la femme a tendance un
peu à je pasz moi l'expression mais la
dernière route du Carros elle aura
tendance à se sacrifier dans le budget
et pas aller sur une pratique sportive
ce qui est dommage parce que il y a des
vrais tarifs promotionnels dont il faut
profiter justement en tant que femme
lors le tennis c'est vrai que c'est
cette réputation de de sport
techniquement difficile parce qu'on sait
que c'est C as là qui qui pose problème
un petit peu pour les les nouveaux alors
effectivement en fait pour pour en
discuter avec les les femmes qui
viennent notamement aux animations bal
rose la première chose qu'elle vous dit
c'est mais moi je n'y arriverai jamais
il faut courir il faut taper dans une
balle je c'est très rare quand j'arrive
à taper dans la balle alors tout le tout
l'enjeu c'est de leur montrer que Ben
même si on tape de temps en à côté de la
balle ça peut être très drôle on peut
venir entre copines et puis au bout de
de quelques de quelques temps de
pratique et bien on arrive à s'amuser
même si on n'est pas capable de de
rivaliser avec les plus forts sur cette
opération balerose l'objectif quel
est-il c'est d'aller recruter des
adultes plutôt des jeunes pour essayer
de les former derrière et les fidéliser
dans cette discipline alors vous avez
tout dit dans la dans la question
c'estàdire qu'effectivement c'est une
opération promotionnelle ligue avec etor
on parlera en terme d'outils de support
de communication pour aider les clubs
mais avec les clubs participants
aujourd'hui c'est 35 clubs participant
la première année mais j'anticipe
peut-être des questions c'était
seulement 16 clubs participants donc on
on
progresse à la limite c'est le contexte
de chaque club et pour recevoir des
nouvelles jeunes filles mais plutôt des
des nouvelles adultes femmes voilà avec
des tarifs promotionnels et des aides et
un soutien de la Ligue bon en tant que
joueur je vais l'avouer je suis joueur
de tennis c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a
aussi les enfants de l'école de tennis
et les mamans qui viennent les les
amener au cours ça pourrait être une
cible justement les MRE des écoles parce
qu'on sait qu'il y a des clubs qui
mettent en place des formules pour les
les parents d'enfants et c'est plutôt
intéressant financièrement là aussi pour
l'or l'or comme vous voulez alors je
parle juste de de vécu en fait dans le
le club où je suis il y a une une
animation qui a très bien marché le
mercredi matin quand les mamans amènent
enfin emmènent leurs enfants à l'école
de tennis et qu'elle reste sur le le
bord du cours à regarder comment ça se
passe et cetera et ben finalement on met
une une raquette en main et on leur dit
venez on vous emmène sur le cours et
pendant l'heure de cours de votre enfant
mais vous allez vous allez essayer et
finalement c'est un bon moyen pour les
les mamans soit de s'y mettre soit de
s'y remettre de découvrir voilà et très
enfin de façon très drôle on les
retrouve bien souvent sur le cours avec
leurs enfants à d'autres moments voilà
donc c'est c'est un autre biaet pour
pour recruter des des mamans ou ou ou
des jeunes femmes qui qui se disent
après tout pourquoi pas pourquoi pas le
tennis puisque je pourrais aller jouer
avec avec mes enfants et cela se passe
votre club c'est alors moi je suis au
Tennis Club de voisin et c'est c'est
tout à fait empirique comme comme
expérience mais ça a très bien
fonctionner il y a un autre problème on
va dire au niveau des chiffres c'est le
renouvellement des licences c'est vrai
que ça c'est toujours compliqué de
fidéliser une adhérente plus qu'un
adhérent dans un club Stéphane alors
paradoxalement
à travers toutes les actions mais c'est
bien le le je vais rebondir sur
l'exemple donné par l'or notre
problématique ligue nous finalement
c'est de partager tout existe en terme
d'action les les clubs font font
vraiment des bonnes choses vis-à-vis du
renouvellement et aussi parfois de
nouvelles notre problématique à nous
c'est c'est finalement partager les
bonnes pratiques c'est que notre rôle
Lig sur le département c'est de tiens ça
a marché dans tel rôle de communication
très fort et d'change ça si ça a marché
dans le club prenez cette bonne solution
et adaptezla donc il y en a plusieurs
enfin a il faudait plus de 10 minutes
pour pour faire le le côté exhaustif par
contre sur le renouvellement ce ce ça ça
marche bien on est en progrès seul petit
bémol sur le renouvellement et ça
rejoint le segment nouveau ou nouvel euh
c'est là où on les gens s'inscrivent une
année euh et pour des problématiques de
on disait de de B là on est sur le
tennis féminin de sport difficile mais
aussi de partenaire mais aussi de voilà
on va rester dans un club parce qu'on a
des partenaires on a un réseau de
partenaires on doit rentrer dans un
groupe et cette difficultés là elle est
incontenable on qu'on a des taux de
d'abandon pour les nouveaux qui sont
trop élevés puisque pratiquement une
nouvelle femme qui vient de s'inscrire
nous quitte au bout d'une année alors
c'est pas propre au tennis ça c'est des
chiffres qu'on retrouve malheureusement
dans beaucoup de sports les gens
s'inscrivent parfois mais pour des
raisons qu'on VI d'expliquer qu'on vient
d'évoquer les gens renouvellent pas et
alors pour les jeunes filles qui
pourraient s'inscrire éventuellement
est-ce qu'elle ne manque pas aussi d'un
modèle les garçons peuvent s'identifier
à Joe wilfri Songa Richard Gasquet
Marion Bartoli a pris sa retraite après
sa victoire sur wiblodon ça peut être
aussi un un point un point clé ça
d'avoir une jeeuse vers qui s'identifier
oui tout à fait enfin à tel point que
moi j'ai une une de mes une de mes
filles qui a 7 ans et qui a fini par me
dire mais en fait le tennis c'est un
sport de garçon il y a pas de bonnes
joueus et c'est vrai qu' elles n'ont pas
de modèle donc déjà elles sont pas
nombreuses sur les cours mais en plus il
y a pas de il y a pas de figure
emblématique et forcément ça nous
aiderait ça nous aiderait dernière
question alors comment justement
concrètement bah vous aidez les clubs à
essayer de d'attirer ces femmes sur les
cours de tennis alors très concrètement
en fait dans le le rôle de facilitateur
et de accompagnateur en fait des des
différents clubs pour l'opération bal
rose on a mis en place un certain nombre
de de supports dédiés que chaque club
peut retrouver dans la boîte à outils
qui se trouve sur le site internet de la
Ligue euh donc on a une affiche
générique qui est personnalisable par
chaque club c'est-à-dire que puisque
forcément chaque club ne va pas faire
son son animation le même jour donc ils
ont un fond un fond d'affiche qu's vont
personnaliser de même pour une
invitation avec un Coupeau réponse
l'invitation est très simple c'est un
petit format 5 qu'on peut distribuer
aussi bien dans le club que chez les
commerçants et cetera il y a une
animation flash qui est téléchargeable à
partir du site et que voilà les clubs
mettent mettent en place sur leur site
internet ou sur les écrans télé dans
leur clubh
et puis ben évidemment il y a le site
internet de la Ligue où on a une
rubrique actu club qui est fait qui est
faite essentiellement pour Ben pour
relayer ce qui se passe dans chacun des
clubs voilà et et pour compléter je on
laisse toute liberté toute l'initiative
de chaque club de mettre l'action
d'animation quiil souhaite et nous on
apporte un une aide sur des des
animations découvertes voilà quatre
séances financées par la Ligue des é
très bien merci beaucoup à tous les deux
et donc si les femmes téléspectatrices
veulent découvrir le le tennis
l'opération ball roue donc jusqu'au 30
juin prochain dans 35 clubs du
département merci beaucoup d'être passé
sur le 78 sport allez on passe à la
suite du programme et du
football pour le compte de la 20e
journée de promotion d'honneur Guill
encours 11e recevait la lanterne rouge
saclou et pour le SG un succès était
impératif pour s'accrocher à un espoir
de maintien Patrick Jacques de dixmud
pour les
images en cas de victoire face à
saintclou guyencour pouvait encore
croire au maintien en promotion d'onneur
dans cette mission les joueurs de Jul
talmose prennent vite les choses en main
face à la plus mauvaise défense du
championnat à la réception de ce superbe
une de par-dessus la défense salive gay
glisse le ballon sous le gardien et
délivre le SG après cet éclair comment
dire et bien plus grand chose à se
mettre sous la dent jusqu'à la pause
saclou se montant dangereux que sur
quelques rares coup de pied arrêté mais
dans ce match de la peur les esprits
s'échauffent rapidement retour des
vestiaires l'ombre de la relégation
prend le pas sur le jeu d'abord sur
cette simulation de l'attaquant jaune et
bleu et ensuite sur ce tac le Guill en
courtois pour le moins
dangereux dans cet attroupement
l'entraîneur joueur jus de Tal morose
per Sner résultat morose et Jérôme
bonadin pour saclou sont expulsés sur
tension moins le premier donc j'ai pas
on n pas su un petit peu maîtriser nos
ner on va dire donc bon en S que c'était
un match voilà où il y avait beaucoup de
nervosité parce que bah le maintien se
joue au bout donc dur à maîtriser les
dernières minutes de la rencontre seront
plutôt haché au menu des fautes en
pagaille et puis encore des fautes et le
SG terminera même le match à U sur cette
intervention makital récolte un deuxième
carton jaune synonyme d'expulsion
qu'importe
cour victoire le SG s'impose 1 à0 un 4
match sans défaite qui Perm au ctinois
de croire au maintien absolument gagner
prendre les 4 points et donc ce qu'on a
réussi à faire je pense que résultat
mérité même si même si on a sur la deè
mi-temp on a moins joué le jeu ét
beaucoup haché donc mais bon victoire
victoire mérité quand même
final et vous allez le voir au
classement de cette pou de Promotion
d'Honneur tout est encore jouable en vue
du maintien pour loui encour les hommes
de jus talmoro sont toujours 11e avec 38
points mais surtout ils sont désormais à
égalité de points avec sa Mor et à une
longueur du 9e luia maabi Paris deux
concurrents qui ont perdu ce weekend il
reste donc encore trois match aguille en
cours pour se maintenir dont deux
rencontres face à des concurrents
directs saint morort lors de la
prochaine journée le 18 mai à domicile
et à luugia maabi pour le compte de la
21e journée avant de recevoir en clôture
du championnat l'actuel leader fleurri
mais regiss et pour être complet sur la
péage dans la poule B trappe c'est
lourdement incliné à domicile face au
leader nanire 3 buts à Z0 les trapistes
conservent tout de même leur 7e place au
classement allez on passe à l'avion et
on va dans les il est le premier pilote
instructeur de planeur handicapé de
France à 29 ans Antoine Motillon passe
désormais son temps entre les nuages
pourtant il y a 9 ans il regardait les
avions d'en bas portrait d'un passionné
qui a ouvert la voix image d'Olivier
manisal il vient de recevoir ses
nouvelles ailes et depuis 2005 Antoine
mtillon ne les quitte plus il y a 9 ans
quelques temps après un accident de moto
qui le rend paraplégique et à la suite
d'une année de rééducation il arrive au
club de Ben pour un baptême de planeur
de retour sur terre il n'a qu'une envie
des colère à nouveau comme pour oublier
son handicap comme pour retrouver sa
libertéous parce que il fallait
convaincre que on pouvait le faire et
que on était finalement des pilotes
comme tout le monde que notre équipement
dans le planeur était complètement
transparent pour un élève moi ça
m'arrive souvent de faire des journées
d'instruction où les gens qui me
connaissent pas quand il me voient
descendre dans mon fauteuil le soir il
dis c toi le fauteuil c'est ça c'est
c'est magique quoi cette petite molette
est la seule différence entre le planeur
d'Antoine et celui d'un pilote valide
elle lui permet de contrôler les pédales
sous le gouvernail comme un signe du
destin ancien couvreur a voulu
naturellement prendre de la hauteur et
rester en apesanteur on a pris quelques
mètres de plus et puis puis après c'est
devenu un peu donc une passion et d'une
passion je me suis dit bon bah pourquoi
pas devenir instructeur donc là c'était
un peu plus compliqué parce que ça avait
jamais été
fait
après 5 années passées dans les nuages
Antoine se lance dans la formation
d'instructeur il devient ainsi le
premier pilote de planeur handicapé de
France maître des a mais livinois a dû
apprendre à surfer sur les courants pour
regarder le monde d'en haut Antoine est
un fin pilote on va dire c'est un gars
qui qui sent les choses peut-être plus
que d'autres finalement parce que dans
la trè dimension je pense que on dit
souvent on pilote aux fesses et c'est
vrai en VO la voir en pilote au f dans
la mesure où on on sent quelques
sensation qui nous incite à penser que
c'est là qu'elle est cette pompe donc
dans ce domaine Antoine est est bon est
très très bon depuis son diplôme Antoine
plane en compétition nationale et
internationale une chose est sûre ce
passionné deser a ouvert une voie dans
le ciel il souhaite désormais faire de
sa passion son métier pour continuer de
planer pour être libre au milieu des
nuages essentiel des résultats du
weekend en rugby ce weekend plaisir
jouer son 32e de finale allée de fédéral
3 à Puil Borau charante maritime et les
joueurs de Philippe Béard se sont
inclinés de qu petits points 11 à 7 ils
conservent tout de même toutes leur
chance de qualification en cas de large
victoire ce dimanche pour le retour à
plaisir en football 24e journée de
Division d'Honneur Versailles recevait
le leader lac boulog bille en cours et
défaite logique un but à 0 les joueurs
de David jiges sortent désormais du
podium et sont 4e chez les femmes
football toujours pour le compte de la
15e journée de promotion d'honneur et l'
en cours 7e recevait ce samedi le 9e
Argenteuil au stade Pierre de Coubertin
et dans un match assez ferméin il faut
le dire les deux équipes vont se séparer
assez logiquement sur un match nul un
but partout les Amazones n'ont plus
gagné depuis un mois une victoire 1-0
face à voréal les joueuses de danilegle
conservent tout de même leur 7e place au
classement général à trois journées de
la fin du championnat il y avait du
tennis et c'était la reprise ce weekend
du championnat de France par équipe
plaisir seul club d'ésivline à avoir
trois équipes engagées à ce niveau étent
sur le pont à domicile les premiers
weekends très positifs pour les joueurs
Plaisirois chez les hommes deux
victoires contre le Stade de vanve et
Ancy respectivement 5 matchs à 1 et 6
matchs à 0 chez les femmes en National 1
B plaisir à concéder le nul face à
mont-sain-martin 3 partout en ball 10e
journée de la 2è phase du championnat de
France des moins de 18 ans plaisir se
déplacait chez le leader créteille et
les joueurs d'Alexandre taer se sont
logiquement inclinés 40 à 31 et vous
allez le voir au classement les
Plaisirois terminent donc cette seconde
phase 5e de leur pouol avec 18 points un
bilan de 4 victoires pour six défaites
pour une première expérience à ce niveau
en encourageante plaisir accueillera les
è de finale et les quarts de la
compétition et pourra y jouer quelques
matchs de classement à la Miet cela fait
désormais quasiment 5 mois que le
vélodrome de 50 ans en Yveline a ouvert
ses portes évidemment une telle
structure a modifié les habitudes des
clubs aux alentours c'est notamment le
cas de vilizi qui compte dans ses rend
le champion d'Europe master du kilomètre
Yan dujarrier désormais tous les samedis
matins les cyclistes vézéens se
réunissent sur l'anneau 5antinois si le
club créé en 1970 reste un club de route
par tradition vzyi a créé un pôle piste
avec 16 membres déjà la piste de
Saint-Quentin c'est aussi le moyen idéal
d'attirer plus de jeunes vers la
pratique du vélo l'ouverture du
Vélodrome nous a apporté une une
cohésion déjà l'intérêt pour la piste et
cela a permis à une quinzaine de
coureurs de découvrir la piste en tant
que débutant et maintenant ils sont ils
sont passés au stade de confirmer mais
et puis ça crée une émulation et ça crée
vraiment une cohésion au sein des
coureurs du club et lundi prochain
évidemment dans le prochain 7 h sport
nous vous présenterons un dossier
complet sur les conséquences de
l'implantation du Vélodrome pour le
cyclisme local en baseball 4e journée de
Division 2 simple formalité pour Montini
àunquerque les cougard ont gagné les
deux matchs 199 à 0 et 8 à 0 il se isent
du coup à la 2e place du classement
footus on jou ce weekend la dernière
journée de la phase régulière du
championnat de France élite et les
Templiers ont fini en beauté par un
carton à Fontenis sous bois 38 à 6 les
joueurs d'Emmanuel Charet terminent 2e
cette phase régulière et peuvent
préparer sereinement les playoffs c'est
la fin de ce 78 sport merci de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi prochain même
heure même
lieu